I'm not going to do a cute intro this is
a spoiler for the movie so if you have
not seen the movie yet I would recommend
not watching this
so spider-man homecoming the movie is
out I did my review it contains no
spoilers and not spoilers the spoils are
on the back end so if you want to spoil
it free watch the first half of that
review I'm not going there on that now
there's one specific spoiler that I want
to talk about I gave my warning at the
front so I'm just going to launch right
into it okay and that is the reveal of
Zenda is character of michelle saying my
friends call me MJ effectively saying
this is Mary this is this universes
equivalent of Mary Jane Watson and I
want to talk about that change and why I
think it's brilliant
actually I need to revise that it's not
the change that I think is brilliant I'm
not actually going to talk about whether
or not it was a good idea to make the
notable changes to the character that
they did either in terms of her rate I'm
definitely not touching that I dealt
with enough of that crap when I talk
about ghost in the shell' nor am i going
to talk about the significant
differences in terms of characterization
and her place in Peters social circle
that this represents you may like that
change you may not like that change I'm
not talking about whether the
characterization alterations are a good
or a bad thing what I am going to talk
about is why I think the manner in which
the revealed that she's kidding this
character Michelle is MJ is genius and
was handled brilliantly again I'm not
here to discuss whether or not the
character changes are a good thing if
you feel they're a bad thing I hope
you'll still stick around and hear me
out on why I think the reveal is well
handled so let's just recap real quickly
we've seen this character Michelle
throughout the movie across the thing
just interacting with Peter interacting
with Ned she's part of the academic
decathlon thing we've seen her around
she's part of the social circle she's
just there it kind of really in the same
way that Ned is there and Liz is there
and Flash's there she's just part of the
group and we get to see her dynamic with
we get to see how people are around her
so we get a sense of her and and just as
Michele okay cool so she's been around
and then at the very end when she feels
more tight with the group she says my
friends call me MJ and for me that was a
big light a moment now that happens like
right at the very like movies
effectively over by the time that
happens it practically could have been a
post-credits sequence so that revealed
is the best way to handle this kind of
significant change because it shows that
they understood the significance of the
changes that they were making it showed
respect for the character now again if
you feel that what the changes to the
characters are a disrespectful I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about the
way in which the reveal is handled I
feel so does a great deal of respect for
the character because it shows an
understanding that what they were doing
was significant and it had to be
delivered in the correct fashion because
if you want to look at something like
say Jimmy Olsen in BBS which I know is a
little one weird one to talk about
because I'm the theatrical I didn't say
his name and it came up more and the
extended end was confirmed by doesn't
make it what but let's just the the guy
who just gets shot at the very beginning
of Batman V Superman that's Jimmy Olsen
apparently that is an incredibly
disrespectful way to do a major
character alteration and I'm not just
saying you can't you know do some big
shifts with a character like Jimmy or
even kill them off necessarily but to
basically go oh you want your Jimmy
Olsen here's your Jimmy Olsen
bang that is disrespectful it's
disrespectful to the character it's
disrespectful to anyone who feels the
character is important to Superman and
some people think he's done some people
think is very important but it shows a
lack of understanding that the decision
to kill Jimmy Olsen is an important one
and a significant one they didn't seem
to care they did it haphazardly and the
tone in which they talked about doing it
reinforces that this shows a respect for
the character because I've actually had
a discussion with some of my friends who
are more okay with her
on being this universe's version of NJ
than others so I've heard that
conversation but the thing is I think
about myself if she had been called MJ
from the beginning and we knew that's
who she was immediately I probably would
have rejected the idea or at least by
the end I would have been swallowing it
really reluctantly because it had been
named MJ as soon as we saw her my brain
immediately would have started
cataloging every reason why this
characterization is unlike MJ how she's
not the same popular it girl how she's
not the social butterfly how she doesn't
have people fawning over her beauty how
her relationship with Peter is
completely different at this point I
mean granted he's interested in another
girl but unless how so much of this is
different and my brain would have been
if not outright rejecting it would have
been challenging this idea of this
character as MJ right from the get-go
and it would have been distracting it
would have taken me out of the movie it
would have become something that I do in
nitpick Rand on because it would have
taken me right out of the movie
experience because my brain can't just
roll with what I'm watching is too busy
picking this apart so the fact that it
comes at the very end not only meant
that it wasn't distracting from the
story as it was happening but
additionally it meant I have the time
and the opportunity to see and get to
like this character before the reveal
happened and to be clear I like this
character again I still see and
understand the arguments and complaints
about how this is a change for the
character of MJ but I liked Michelle I
liked her dynamic with the group it was
weird and it was funny because she was a
bit of an outsider but she had this sort
of natural charisma and nobody would
like treated her like she was weird she
just seemed to voluntarily be like I'm
just going to be you guys go over there
have fun I'll just be over here but she
didn't seem angsty and she didn't you
know I liked her whole dynamic and I
came to like her quite a bit well ahead
of that reveal so because of where we
took the time to put this character in
and put in effort to give us reasons to
potentially
her which in my case it worked for me
then by the end one day when she says my
friends call me MJ I go oh okay and I'm
able to roll with it because rather than
going hears MJ and forcing the
comparison throughout the movies instead
it goes hey you know that character you
already liked yeah yeah I know they
character well that Sanjay huh alright
and that and that was basically where I
live and it was said at first I was like
huh but then almost immediately I went
okay yes now okay I'm good
and I think them that method of delivery
makes it palatable for people who might
have otherwise rejected it and again
there are some people who are going to
reject this change no matter what for a
number of reasons and I'm not you know
there's always going to be that when you
do a significant change to a character
but there is always going to be a
contingent of people who will go with it
if you do it correctly and if you do it
intelligently and if you do it
respectfully which this film I feel
absolutely does and that is why I feel
that the MJ reveal and spider-man
homecoming is brilliantly handled from
from the point which we meet this
character to how she is seeing across
the film to the when the reveal happens
if this decision was made and the
decision was made to change the
character this way of giving that to the
audience I think is a genius way to do
it it was guerrilla tactics it was let's
make them love her first and then let
them know who she is in that she's going
to be important later they put
characterization up front instead of
just slapping the name and hoping that
the automatic recognition of the name
will make us go oh we now care about
this character because it would have
backfired and it didn't because they put
thought into it they were respectful
about it and it was just smartly handled
that's my thoughts and why I think the
MJ reveal is genius what are your
thoughts on all this please don't bring
up the right thing I didn't even talk
about it
okay can we leave that one out but
whatever your other thoughts are drop
them down the comment let's talk about
it don't forget to like subscribe check
me out on Twitter at council geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast also available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]